you know a lot of people are going to
compare this movie to Twilight I think
that's a little unfair from what I've
seen in the world a romance between a
girl and a rotting corpse is more
believable than a romance with a girl in
a sparkly corpse so there that is that's
the world we live in and that is just
real warm bodies I'm just gonna get
right down to this warm bodies is a
romance between a girl and a zombie
amidst a zombie apocalypse that's what
it's about and you hear that you think
yourself with its twilight with zombies
that's just what I think that's what
everyone thinks and that's a justifiable
reaction I get it but there is a little
more to this movie than just that
the zombie the main dude has inner
monologue do you hear his thoughts he's
narrating the movie more or less and
you're like all right so does that mean
he has cognitive thought or his motor
functions just slow they go for some
weird little angle like that which
almost works but then it really doesn't
work because he's acting like a zombie
and you're like well why you acting like
a zombie when you could think like a
human being but then you realize that
ultimately if there were still
blockbusters in the world that we live
in this movie would be found in the
comedy section it's not really meant to
be taken that seriously arguing these
little semantics is like arguing the
fact the wily coyote doesn't actually
drop off the cliff until he looks down
that's just unrealistic I do like the
fact that this movie does touch on the
zombies perspective of the zombie
apocalypse you always see human beings
wiping them out oh my god we gotta save
humanity let's just shoot zombies cuz
they're mindless zombie too like dudes
we have feelings too I can't actually
think to myself that I was seeing that
before so I like seeing that ultimately
in warm bodies the zombie dude sees his
girl and he's like I'm not totally
inhuman because yeah feelings for this
chair and there's a story-based reason
for that also and you actually kind of
buy it you're like oh wait okay I get
that I buy that zombie movie and so they
have to hang out for a few days in close
quarters and so she's like oh well maybe
zombies aren't completely inhuman and
then he's like oh the more Mehran her
the more human I feel so it's just kind
of this symbiotic relationship they got
going on does it sound cheesy yes that's
just because it is cheesy but it's a
it's a rom-com it's a romantic comedy
it's it's coming out around Valentine's
Day I'm just telling you in terms of
Valentine's Day movies there are a
hundred worst movies to get dragged to
than a movie that's a romance between a
girl and a zombie so I guess in short
this movie is just better than it should
have been
it doesn't mean it's like aces the
director of fifty-fifty directs this
movie so you know it's going to have a
little more substance to it than it
should have it's not going to be some
undead romance with sparkly
people rotting people instead of sparkly
people the zombie dude zombie friend who
was like the you know like the funny
douchebag and Hot Tub Time Machine he
was pretty funny too yeah like the
zombie is funny
zombies have humor too everyone needs to
laugh they do this thing where even the
zombies zombies are really bad like
zombies have really bad Lich Essam bees
and they're just evil for everything but
they ultimately had to do that because
of like wolves zombies and humans need a
common threat so did hear hear hear
these things and they clearly exist for
that one particular point and that's it
they're just they're just kind of thrown
in the movie line here when something is
that obvious that it kind of pulls me
out of the movie and I just go oh well
okay there's that John Malkovich is in
the movie he's the girl's father and
he's just really hardcore we're talking
just waste all zombies NRA
badass guy he was perfect in the movie I
thought it was great in the movie he
worked well like if you're gonna have a
zombie apocalypse movie you need a
military guy dude John Malkovich why not
the problem is the movie doesn't
actually hit one genre with full force
it's part zombie apocalypse movie part
romance movie part zombie apocalypse
action movie part comedy part romance
part romantic comedy but it's not
definitively anything it's like little
pieces of a pie that are pretty good
instead of one strong piece that's
awesome so in the end warm bodies is
enjoyable it's cute it's funny it's not
meant to be taken seriously although
it's meant to be taken seriously enough
that keeps it from being a full-blown
comedy if you're looking for the next
Dombey Lander Shaun of the Dead it's not
really going to be warm bodies but I
walked out of the movie going I did
enjoy the movie more than I should have
if you never see warm bodies no one's
gonna fought you for it's like oh wait
the premises of romance between a zombie
and a girl past however for what the
movie is which is a romance between a
girl and a zombie I gotta say warm
bodies is actually surprisingly a good
time no alcohol required maybe the world
is ending because this movie was
enjoyable and that was unexpected a
shittiest twilight no I'm gonna snuff
that out right now where's your favorite
zombie apocalypse movie ever what is it
what would it be whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you